alexeï navalni et le dernier opposant
russe victime d'une tentative
d'empoisonnement
avant lui sergueï skripal en 2018
sergueï skripal un ancien espion russe
réfugié en angleterre ils auraient été
empoisonnés
alexandre litvinenko en 2006 ils se sont
opposés pendant des années et c'est bien
vladimir poutine qui a gagné le combat
mais pas forcément à la loyale
empoisonné son agonie durera trois
semaines et victor iouchtchenko en 2004
le voici avant son hospitalisation le 6
septembre à vienne
suite à des douleurs abdominales et à
des vomissements lorsqu'il sort de la
clinique une semaine plus tard l'homme
est défigurée si les opposants au
pouvoir russe sont souvent victimes
d'empoisonnement ailleurs dans d'autres
pays
certains sont assassinés comme il ya
trois ans le journaliste jamal kassogué
victime d'un sordide assassinat
derrière ce meurtre certains pointent le
pouvoir saoudien
ce sont les dernières images de jamal
khashoggi et de sa fiancée en route pour
le consulat d'arabie saoudite à ankara
plus tard le journaliste saoudien y
pénètre seul il n'en ressortira jamais
et parfois les états vont encore plus
loin en corée du nord le pouvoir
n'hésite pas après une exécution à
effacer toute trace de l'existence de la
victime
sur les photos documents officiels
exemple avec l'oncle du leader kim jong
hoon tué en 2013 yang song-thaek
disparaît des photos et vidéos
comme s'il n'avait jamais existé on voit
qu'il jardin en train de faire une
visite officielle sur la photo de gauche
vous avec chanson take qui est encadré
donc ce longues et sur la photo de
droite il a disparu alors ça c'est une
méthode très traditionnelle en corée du
nord
on efface sur les films de propagande
les personnes qui ne sont qu elles sont
jugées indésirables à chaque régime
autoritaire sa technique
en chine les t'appeler
également commettre des disparitions
forcées des stars des hommes d'affaires
se volatilise du jour au lendemain
à chaque fois un retentissement
médiatique bien au-delà des frontières
de l' empire du milieu comme en 2018
avec l'actrice fan bingbing où est elle
la superstar du cinéma chinois n'a plus
donné signe de vie depuis maintenant
trois mois fan bing bing est l'actrice
la mieux payée du pays 40 millions
d'euros
soupçonnés de fraude fiscale elle
pourrait être entre les mains des
autorités prison en résidence surveillée
pour l'exemple des personnalités qui
finissent par réapparaître dernier en
date le milliardaire jack ma fondateur
du site alibaba il a disparu pendant
près de trois mois après avoir critiqué
la politique financière de son pays il
est réapparu dans une vidéo le 20
janvier dernier
[Musique]